well hello there watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages it's time then to see what's
making the headlines with the chief
political correspondent for the guardian
jessica elgot and the columnist for the
article ali mirage both of them with us
from now until just before midnight so
front pages then let's take a look shall
we starting with the metro which leads
with the government's announcements
today concerning covet vaccines and
preventative measures to be taken
against the virus during the forthcoming
winter months a coveted winter warner
their headline
telegraph calls the prospect of further
difficulties the specter of winter
lockdown but the daily mail takes a more
strident tone declaring surprise it's
back to panic stations
the guardian relaying a warning to boris
johnson from scientific advisers
plan for the worst the mirror highlights
the prime minister's covid plan b
and the style goes with the government's
chief medical officer debunking claims
made by the singer nicki minaj as to the
government's or the coveted vaccines
effect rather on the male anatomy the
financial times reports that the
government has been forced to delay the
implementation of checks on eu goods at
uk borders to try to keep supplies
moving after brexit
and the sun going with a smiling prince
william and david beckham at the papers
who cares wins awards
so we're joined then by jessica elgott
and ali mirage with their thoughts for
today welcome to both of you and you've
picked the daily telegraph to start with
the specter of winter lockdown returns
uh we've got plan a first though ali um
plan b follows not much of a mention of
lockdown to be fair in plan b
no but uh again i think this is uh this
has been announced today plan a plan b
plan a essentially is really focusing on
giving booster jabs to the over 50s
prioritizing them
and prioritizing people with
immunosuppressed conditions
and also we also know that uh the
government is now also trying to focus
on the rollout of jabs to 12 to 15 year
olds uh which last week the joint
committee on vaccination and even
immunization said it was a very close
call
as to whether it could be should be done
or not and it was very marginal and then
the four chief medical officers across
the uk decided that on balance it was
worth doing uh to ensure that kids
education does not get disrupted so
that's another element of it um but plan
b has been kept in reserve which is if
things do get worse and at the moment
the hospitalization rate is rising it's
much higher than it was at the the high
peak last year we also have an infection
rate of 30 000 a day uh the issue here
is that the infection rate whilst it's
high uh still not leading to a high
death rate which is good so that link
seems to have been uh at least broken to
a degree if not completely severed plan
b is really focusing around the fact
that you could potentially have
lockdowns you might have the return of
this idea of vaccination passports
which have been kicked into the long
grass for now but the government's
keeping its options open yeah passports
working from home face masks um i mean i
i repeat not a great deal of mention
about the possibility of keeping shops
or pubs closed or the nighttime economy
or schools closing et cetera et cetera
and abc news australia i was intrigued
to see in their reporting of this story
said britain is preparing for a long
virulent winter without a single
lockdown can they pull it off and is
that what most people in britain are
wondering too do you think jessica
i think if you look at what the
government's plan b is and compare it to
some of the restrictions that we've gone
through and it it's something that is is
barely you know it's really barely
anything and and plenty of the of the of
the um
parts of the toolkit if you like as it
was described in in plan b are things
that people a lot of people are still
pretty much doing anyway it involves you
know uh extra mask wearing in shops and
on public transport i mean that's
definitely wayne did i you know i don't
know about you but i've certainly
noticed less people wearing them but
there's certainly still a lot of people
still wearing masks in shops and on
public transport it also talks about
reintroduction of working from home
advice again a lot of people still have
a kind of hybrid working arrangement a
lot of businesses saying they're not
necessarily expecting of sort of a full
return to the office
sometimes some in some cases maybe not
ever and and in other cases you know
that it's been delayed until next year
so if this is the if this is the toolkit
to deal with you know a massive surge of
infections um you know it it it
still seems somewhat limited and i
suppose what they mean by the specter of
a lockdown is the government's still
reserving the right to do it it still
has the power to do it and even though
we know they're repeating some of the
measures in the coronavirus act actually
a lot of the powers come anyway from the
public health act in in 1984 so the
government's still going to be able to
close businesses close schools
if it needs to do so but i think boris
johnson is intending to signal that
that's not what he he wants to do and
they'll have to be dragged kicking and
screaming to do it yes it's a little bit
like we suddenly had a tier 4 wasn't it
last winter the metro a covid winter
warner and certainly the message from
professor chris witte was
amongst other things delta is a very bad
variant it's the reason we and the rest
of the world have had such a difficult
year we've not faced winter with delta
highly transmissible it is a possible
combination of winter events plus delta
that ministers may want to trigger all
or some of plan b
and quite frankly they don't know how we
will behave whether we do still reduce
our contacts which will dictate
how we get through this winter alley
that's right i mean look i think
what they're doing at the moment is
keeping
all options open and they don't want to
put out hostage's fortunes so i think
there as jessica said they've got a
toolkit out there and as boris johnson
himself said you don't want to play all
your shots at once so they've just got
various options here but look chris
whitty's talking about the delta variant
we know that um you can have issues with
various variants coming through and then
this plays into a wider issue about
should we really be focusing on giving
second jabs or booster jabs rather to
our own population rather than
vaccinating uh people in other parts of
the world that haven't even had a first
job and i think there are some people
certainly in the labour party pushing
this line that we're not safe until
we're all safe kind of argument
and this sort of comes into it but i do
think that boris johnson does have to
bear in mind
the
murmurings on his own back benches we've
heard from mark harper the head of the
covid recovery group uh today that he
believes that testing for school kids
should be abandoned because it affects
their mental health we've got hugh
merriman the chairman of the transport
select committee uh requesting that pcr
tests should be dropped for people
coming back from holidays so there are a
lot of there's a lot of unease on the
touring back benches right now and a lot
of groans in parliament they when
sergeant javid made some of these
announcements on plan b so i think the
government and the prime minister in
particular want to proceed with caution
and want to try and leave it up to us to
be sensible and keep these measures in
reserve as a last resort yes which which
takes us tonally at least to the daily
mail surprise it's back to panic
stations um and sir patrick valencia's
message or the old message that he
always had go fast go hard with
restrictions won't please people um who
believe what the daily mail says uh
jessica
yes he you know he said that experience
his experience of battling the rise says
you know you have to go earlier than you
think you want to you have to go harder
than you think you want to
um and he called you know he said that
the uk was now at a pivot point and it
all feels very different to the way that
this was briefed to the sunday
newspapers and the way that downing
street
had hoped to present what this winter
plan meant i.e you know we've got these
kind of toolkits in the reserve they're
relatively moderate measures and we're
gonna uh abolish you know some of the
measures that we've got in the
coronavirus act
actually you know what we're hearing
from scientists and i think we'll go on
to talk about what what sage
has advised uh in a few moments time and
you know is that actually we are at
quite a critical moment where we need to
to start making decisions about if any
kind of gentle interventions ones that
don't actually really cost the economy
an awful lot something like things like
mask wearing which is still mandatory in
some in some part in some parts of the
country in scotland and in wales and you
know whether that is actually something
to start intervening now rather than
waiting for a moment where that may not
be enough yes the uh the sort of sage
spin-off group that uh uh
offers advice on modeling um has
released its data today that's in the
guardian alley between 2 000 and 7 000
people a day could be hospitalized with
covid in england next month unless the
government urgently implements a basket
of measures um i think they actually say
that hospital occupancy in england is
currently around 6200 that was the data
from when they issued this uh certainly
the data given today was that it's it's
over 8200 um but they say 6200 is only
two and a half
doubling times away from the peak seen
in january 2021 of 34 000. that's quite
a quick route to not great numbers isn't
it ali
i think that's right and again you know
sage are putting out this warning shot
across the bowels in terms of
again falling off from jessica's point
about the government being encouraged to
act uh fast and hard when it needs to
and we learned this from the pandemic
last year we were late slightly later
than others to lock down which meant we
had to stay and lock down longer than we
might have wanted to uh and that's a
lesson that we need to learn here but i
do think that the prime minister is also
facing a political reality here in the
sense that you could see that his own
backbenchers i mean despite what the
scientists say on the one hand the prime
minister's got to tread that fine line
between what the scientists are saying
whose job it is to prevent deaths i mean
they've got one single metric which is
to prevent deaths and the prime
minister's got to take into account
other things in terms of the recovery of
the economy uh people's mental health
physical health uh the impact on the nhs
waiting list of of people actually going
into hospitals so he's got to factor
into a whole range of things here and
he's also got a factor in the feelings
and the the strong the strong emotions
of his back benches and this is why
there was this reversal on covered
vaccination which took place over the
weekend because having brought in that
national insurance rise last week with
um with i think tory back benches sort
of swallowed i just think that there was
a feeling amongst the government that
they couldn't push it too far and that
they had to shelve this covered
vaccination thing at least for now which
is exactly what's happened so it's
difficult one for the prime minister in
the government but i think they've just
got it about right so far as to whether
that continues we'll have to wait and
see yes i know you want to talk about
the daily star as well let's just show
you that uh very quickly uh this is
singer nicki minaj who
who was criticized let's put it that way
by professor chris witte today uh people
like that should be ashamed of
themselves he suggested we'll talk about
that one later shall we a lot more still
to come including we will take a look at
the latest situation with incoming eu
goods after brexit stay with us
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview joining me this evening
for more uh jessica elgott and ali
mirage welcome back to both of you um
it's not yet 100 days to christmas but
already there are warnings about getting
christmas gifts in
and meanwhile or because of
mr johnson the ft tells us it's forced
to delay brexit border checks on eu
goods now it's not just brexit is it um
that's causing the difficulties it's the
pandemic uh it's the difficulty of
containers but but the brexit business
is an interesting decision today jessica
yeah i mean
we've sort of ended up in quite odd
situation i think a new diploma makes
this point at the front on the front of
the ft where you know it's all about
kind of take brexit was all about taking
back control but in fact what we've had
to do is entirely relinquish control
on on uh lots of the checks that we
might do on importing things that coming
into coming into the country so
and you know the government's also
you know delaying um any paperwork
around all sorts of kind of food and
animal products things like eggs and
even like those kind of composite
products like like lasagna and like a
pepperoni pizza or
something like that and the government's
basically saying it's got no choice
because of the pressures there are on on
global supply chain chains and and
in the written in the the statement from
penny morden you know she she starts by
blaming the pandemic uh and says you
know there's obviously precious
the eu is under the these these
pressures as well but that's what's kind
of how to force
these decisions but it's not a
comfortable position to have to be in
yeah the empty shelves is is not a good
look is it i suppose ali um what's your
view on this
well i i think uh you know to follow on
from what jessica was saying i think it
is a difficult position and i think it's
a confluence of factors resulting in a
perfect storm for the government here
it's not just uh brexit i mean brexit
has created its own issues uh most
notably until recently uh in the with
this border in the irish sea issue with
which has become known as the sausage
wars um
rather flippantly but i mean this is all
to do with cold meats being moved to uh
northern ireland and the fact that um
they were meant to be checks uh imposed
before they went um across the irish sea
now that has caused a lot of problems
not only with unionists in northern
ireland but in a broader issue it's
causing political tension in in northern
ireland and you then got this other
issue now where lord frost sort of under
the radar and quite quietly has decided
to
push back checks that were meant to be
imposed actually this year to next year
so uh certification of of uh on health
grounds of certain imports etc will now
be kicking in in july next year which is
as he as he himself says it's a
pragmatic issue but you also add into
the fact anna that we've got a shortage
of a hundred thousand uh lorry drivers
at the moment uh we've got issues with
pay uh and and structural uh problems
with that um and and a lot of thirty
thousand lorry driver tests about to be
postponed because of the pandemic so
you've got this brexit issue you've got
the lorry driver issue
and you've got general supply chain
squeeze and as jessica says the eu's
sitting pretty because they're imposing
their checks on us and unfortunately at
the moment we can't impose our checks on
them